alors moi personnellement j'ai toujours
pensé qu'on pourrait mettre la
construction des collèges et des lycées
sur un même niveau de collectivités
territoriales qui permettrait évidemment
d'avoir
une seule administration
pour construire enfin pour cette mission
qui est essentiellement une mission de
construction de bâtiments il faut bien
bien mesuré et qu' elle n'aime pas qu'on
cherche absolument à faire des économies
rationalisation
rationaliser pardon et à mutualiser je
pense que c'était une
bonne chose assez simple et assez
symbolique que de rassembler sur un même
niveau de collectivités territoriales
cette construction des lycées et des
collèges
alors qu'est ce qui a bloqué
ce qui bloque c'est c'est naturellement
des collectivités qui ne veulent pas
lâcher de compétence c'est c'est ça le
sait ça le sujet
alors qu'on pourrait très bien imaginer
que en transférant cette compétence on
en garde d'autres ou même on en
transfert d'autres
mais c'est très difficile effectivement
il ya toujours de bonnes raisons
toujours de bonnes raisons
quelques-uns de mes collègues
peuvent penser que
je suis un peu sévère vis-à-vis des
départements je pense qu'ils ont tort de
certains goûtent et surtout
parce que ça donne une image au fond
qui n'est pas positive et qu'il n'est
pas suffisamment qui montre pas
suffisamment qu'ils ont
besoin de la réforme